um, very uncomfortable symptoms that hit
people who suffer from this condition.
Now, when we listen to this report
shortly, you'll notice that Jordan
slowly notices the onset of this
toxicity, starts to feel worse. He'll
actually describe feeling weak,
suffering from an old neurological
injury that's more recently been causing
akathisia.
Akathisia is the worst thing I've ever
seen anyone go through.
Everything you own, from your clothes to
your car, to your wife or your husband,
is going to forget you and move on and
be replaced the moment you die. That's
what Allah says,
"Takathur hatta zurtumul maqabir." You
are busy with the worldly affairs until
you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, Masjid Norway, the one that we
built, is looking to another masjid
around the area of Norway, subhanallah,
where there's so many Muslims that do
not have somewhere to pray. This masjid
is only $500,000, and any donation that
you give will go towards your akhirah
because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this masjid, inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000, and
believe me, if every single one of us
give £1, £10, £100, £1,000, that's going
to be something you will never regret on
Yawm al-Qiyamah, and everything that you
lose is going to perish and go, but your
deeds on Yawm al-Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link, inshallah. Let's get
to the Here is a disease in a nutshell,
and look at this, subhanallah. Look at
what the disease is actually about. This
is a doctor that explains that. that I
want to bring your attention to cuz this
is uh things that Jordan has talked
about experiencing. So, firstly is
akathisia, this need to move around and
pace. You'll hear him describe that. Um,
we also have things like balance
problems, um, heart rate rhythm
irregularities or blood pressure issues,
and this can make it seem like you're
dying of another condition. You A lot of
people don't relate this back to benzos.
There are things like, um, stabbing
pains, burning, aching sensations, or
joint pains. Many of these patients have
neurological symptoms in their hands,
they feel numb, sleep disturbances as
well, difficulty focusing, sensitivity
to noise and light. There are a whole
host of, um, very uncomfortable symptoms
that hit people who suffer from this
condition. Now, when we listen to this
report shortly, you'll notice that
Jordan slowly notices the onset of this
toxicity, starts to feel worse. He'll
actually describe feeling weak,
detached, and feeling less joyful, and
then experiencing very severe anxiety.
He's also going to report that when he
goes into a higher dose, it makes him
worse, which is a sign that he's having
a drug toxicity. Cuz usually if you're
taking an anti-anxiety med like
Klonopin, if you go to a higher dose,
your symptoms of anxiety go down, but if
you do that and you get worse, it's a
sign the drug is toxic to your nervous
system. Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala says in
the Quran, and no one knows the soldiers
of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
When we think of soldiers, we think
about atomic weapons, we think about uh
you know, these uh ballistic missiles,
soldiers.
Wallahi, nobody knows the soldiers of
Allah. It can be microorganisms
that are so small
that 6 billion of them can fit in your
little nail.
That I've studied Subhana Allah of the
bacteria.
6 billion of these bacteria can fit in
your little nail here.
Subhana Allah, brothers and sisters.
This is a interview or a podcast or
a
video that was done by Mikhail Peterson.
And then we're going to go to the doctor
who is explaining to us what akathisia,
I think that's what akathisia are, uh is
um
causing.
And the disease in itself
is something as if you give someone hell
on Earth.
And that's not my words. That is the
word of his daughter, this
neuroscientist, this uh neurologist uh
talking about this. Let's go to the
video, brothers and sisters, and make
what of it, inshallah. And just imagine
for a second, brothers and sisters,
before people come and say, "You know
what? Look at you, you know, this person
going through this No, no, no, no, no.
If I
was doing videos supporting ISIS,
massacring innocent Christian children,
and I said to Abu Bakr al-Baghdadi, who
is their leader, God knows probably a
Mossad Mossad agent, and I said, "Abu
Bakr al-Baghdadi and ISIS, give them
hell."
Do you think
anyone would have an atom weight of
sympathy for me
if I was going through a traumatic
experience and I was saying give them
hell and I was going through that hell
myself.
Every single person
would be, including Muslims yes, would
be happy for what I'm going through.
And I'm not saying that I am happy or
sad with this. I'll be honest with you.
I If anything, I'm more happy than sad,
but I'm not saying. I'm saying that this
is a lesson for those who mock, laugh,
and want the destruction of innocent
Palestinian children who have been
massacred. Let's watch Rasha. Hey guys.
This is a video update on dad's health,
as well as a much longer portion of
information about what he's suffering
from,
what a lot of people are suffering from,
unfortunately, and what my experience
with these issues was. These updates are
not fun for me. They're really
stressful. And I would have updated you
guys sooner, but he's still been really
sick, and he got worse over the last few
months.
And I'm 25 weeks pregnant.
And I wasn't able to record anything
without weeping the whole time until
this week, apparently.
Uh
and it stresses out my whole family to
talk about it online, and there's no
point in adding stress to an already
stressful situation, except that because
we're public, dad in particular, it's
also stressful not talking about it
because then rumors get started, and
then that's all people wonder about.
So, here goes.
Okay, there we go. Let's see her
explaining what is it that her dad's
going through. Dad's been suffering from
an old neurological injury that's more
recently been causing akathisia.
Akathisia is the worst thing I've ever
seen anyone go through. That sounds
dramatic, but it's true.
The worst thing you see someone going
through.
I think the worst thing I've seen
someone go through is what the
Palestinians have gone through. The
worst thing I've seen. And um for you,
it's subjective, you know,
but what your dad called on them
Benjamin Netanyahu this come to do
he's going through that hell himself
that he wanted on this innocent
Palestinian children and kids who have
been wrongly oppressed.
Yes.
And what does the Bible say? Your
scripture your scripture says so. The
Bible says in Galatians,
do not be deceived cause it's not to be
mocked. Whatever man says he will reap
its return. Whoever digs a pit will fall
into it if someone rolls a stone it will
come back on them or so in Proverbs.
That's your Bible.
Although other medications can sometimes
cause it and so can sudden cessation
from those medications. That's a huge
trigger.
So like suddenly stopping one of the
medications that can also cause it. And
sometimes people with Parkinson's can
experience it too.
It is intolerable discomfort that makes
people want to crawl out of their skin.
It's a neurological injury really. A lot
of people don't survive it and there's
no quick fix. Although I'll go into how
we've dealt with it before.
Without video taping me sobbing
and it seems like a bunch of my sadness
this week has
turned into anger which
is actually at least more enjoyable for
me but without posting a video of me
sobbing I don't know how to describe how
bad it is in words but I'm going to take
a stab at it.
You guys could look up videos of other
people suffering with it
if you want to. It's catastrophic.
Before I get into it
let me be super clear. Dad has not been
on a psych medication since January
2020. The way she's explaining that like
if I explained anyone they would say bro
that person's going through hell on
earth and brings back memories.
This has been
unbelievably hard on my family. Every
day for the last year has been hell.
I haven't been posting podcasts
regularly online because until a few
days ago I've cried every single day.
My brother is stressed out. My mom is
stressed. I mean, it's impacting so many
people.
Um and of course my dad. Well, the
Palestinian children and kids were
impacted as well. And you know what's
really funny about all of this,
very bizarre, is that's a neurological
disease that you don't know why it's
caused. You You can't stop it cuz you
don't know what it is. Is there a cure?
You don't know.
What the Palestinians were going was
inflicted on another by other human
beings
who've gone through something similar
and they're inflicting on these people.
And your dad
prescribed or prescribed Netanyahu to
give them hell,
which could have been stopped. It could
have not been done.
But look how Allah sent and gave a
disease to your father that you can't
stop it.
At least with the Palestinians, it could
be stopped. Stop it. Stop the killing.
It could be stopped by a human being.
Stop. We know the problem. We know their
evilness, their satanics. Satanist. It
can be stopped. Now a disease has come
where you can't even find the cure and
you cannot stop it. Otherwise, this
would have just crushed us.
I've certainly been walking around in a
state of panic for almost a year now.
Imagine the Palestinian innocent
children that your dad inflicted hell on
them.
Now, my message, like I said before,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has sent the
Prophet Muhammad who is a mercy to
mankind.
And the Prophet dealt with his enemies
in a certain way as well and he had
mercy on a lot of them.
Have you tried the Quran,
Jordan Peterson?
If you firmly believe, which Muhammad
Hijab gave you da'wah and many other
people, and you did not want to know
because of your arrogance thinking the
Western man and the white man, you know,
you're better than us, barbarians.
Have you tried the Quran?
Why don't you try the Quran? Michelle
Robinson, if you're watching this, yes?
Why don't you try the Quran as a remedy?
Why don't you see it? That's your last
chance. I believe this is a last chance
from Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Why
don't you try the Quran?
The Quran is a cure.
If you genuinely are looking for help
and you seek and you call to God and
ask, Allah says, "I respond to the call
of that calls upon me." If you genuinely
call upon God
and
play the Quran, Surah Baqarah. Yes, the
second chapter in the Quran.
I believe this will cure
Jordan Peterson.
Will he do it? Will he doesn't do it?
That's up to him.
But,
like I said before,
what you inflict on them like I'm not
Well, I'm no one that will be happy
against somebody being ill or whatever
it is etc. Yes, unless they're a strong
strong enemy, reckless individuals who
are calling for
the massacre of innocent people who are
unjust, who have desecrated scripture or
whatever it is for that matter.
May God give them worse.
And this is just a reminder.
Be careful what you ask for the
innocent.
For with the oppressed, there is no
barrier between them and their prayers.
And like I said before,
we hope that Jordan Peterson, it's never
too late to turn back to Allah, God,
and use his book he gave as a remedy.
If you carry on stubbornness, this that,
the end is yours and like I told you
said, not many people survive this.
All I'm going to say is that Allah will
never ever
let evil doers get away with what
they're doing.
Yes?
And if I done this
and I spoke like that against a army or
government, Islamic government, a Muslim
government doing this to innocent
Christians, Jews, Hindus, Sikhs, you
name it.
I will be hanged upside down.
I will be assassinated.
But when it's them,
it's fine.
I just wanted to bring that to your
attention, guys, so that the believers
know that Allah Don't ever think Allah
is unaware.
Don't ever think Allah does not know.
This is just If this
is a calamity Allah sent him to for him
to turn back to God, it's a mercy.
If he carries on arrogantly and passes
away then that,
we leave the matter to Allah. I just
wanted to bring that to you guys,
inshallah, and subhanallah, may Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
deal with the oppressors.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.